Question 2 tests that you understand procedures as well as the if construct.
The question is "Which of the following have exactly the same behavior as the procedure below?"
For two procedures to have exactly the same behavior, that means
that no matter what the inputs are, the caller couldn't tell
the difference between the two procedures, so it produces the same output.
They both have the same side effects.
In this case, we've defined a procedure here.
It uses the procedure "test"--we haven't shown you how test is defined.
You should assume that test is a procedure that takes a number
as its input and outputs a Boolean.
But you shouldn't assume anything else about test.
Your goal is no matter what the procedure test does to figure out
if the choice has exactly the same behavior as the procedure showing here.
Here are the choices--check all the choices that have
that have the same behavior as the procedure defined here.